im salon eines luxuriösen hotels in
nutzer
modell liegen als jesus christus für
eine abwandlung eines meisterwerks von
hall bei am werke ist der belgische
comic-künstler peter von hersel alias
erzähle ein universalgelehrter mit
entertainerqualitäten er liebt es dem
publikum zu zeigen dass in der promi
kunst die wahre meisterschaft liegt man
muss auch ein bisschen konkurrieren mit
reality finde ich heute im kunst das ist
auch was schönes dann comics natürlich
die sind mir sind noch die wirkliche
zeichnete wir hatten eine kalligraphie
nicht können gut zeichnen in die moderne
kunst fällt das ein bisschen natürlich
in die christusfigur hat sich das haupt
von cowboy eingeschlichen
die comicfigur geld in belgien als
politisch unkorrekt und selbstgefällig
schon seit über 30 jahren feilt er seele
an dieser figur
ich bin besser geworden das ist kein
vorteil eigentlich ich liebe die
expressionistische sehr primitive kunst
aber der ist schöner geworden ist eine
figur denke das ist sehr wichtig für die
leute um so eine ein rock'n roll dingen
das leben zu haben
jetzt wo er in der schweiz ist darf sich
cowboy hang kann heiligtümern beweisen
auch die gemälde eines ferdinand oder
sind vor ihm nicht sicher
das ist belgische comic tradition auf
den spuren der großen meister wir machen
zu realismus wir sind die generation
nach das zu realismus wir machen das
auch aber wir machen ein tourbus
surrealismus und auch ein populäres
realismus einen fox im fokus so
realismus ich nenne das auch ein
bisschen heimat comic eigentlich in
seinen persönlichen kosmos holt uns der
spanische zeichner miguel gallardo ganz
einfach meist mit dem kugelschreiber
hält er das leben seiner tochter maria
fest maria ist out ist in
am anfang trauerte gallardo dann lernte
er die umstände akzeptieren
indem er sie zeichnete wie es ist noch
mit 20 in vielem auf dem stand einer
fünfjährigen zu sein aber auch ihre
besonderen begabungen
maria kann sich die namen aller menschen
merken die sie jemals getroffen hat das
erste buch über maria habe 13 jahre
gebraucht
das war die zeit ich benötigt habe um
alles was mit maria los war zu verdauen
damit sich ihre geschichte mit einer
anderen sichtweise erzählen konnte mit
einer optimistisch vitalen sichtweise
wende anders als alle anderen auf
autismus
kaum etwas im leben kann einen umwerfen
so scheint es wenn man einen
zeichenstift hat und humor besessen von
details das werk des zeichners pusch
wagner
einer der bekanntesten norwegischen
gegenwartskünstler
ist den großen auftritt im museum
entschuldigung dass ich zu spät komme
der künstler treibt seine
gesellschaftskritik in feinstem tusche
strich bis ins letzte detail als hinge
das leben davon ab wenn es mir nicht
gelungen wäre mein zeichnen zur
perfektion zu treiben
in meinen augen nicht in den augen der
öffentlichkeit dann hätte ich selbst
noch die chance of city
die graphic novel die hier im original
gezeigt wird das ist pusch wagners opus
magnum eine düster futuristische vision
einer gesellschaft in der der mensch
ähnlich wie bei orwell total
kontrolliert ist seit den siebziger
jahren hatte er daran gearbeitet
nach der vollendung verschwand das werk
auf mysteriöse weise
40 jahre nach der ersten zeichnung wurde
es wieder entdeckt
und der künstler in seiner heimat eine
berühmtheit
er der über lange zeit durch alle
sozialen netze gefallen war und
zeitweise auf der straße gelebt hatte
ein außenseiter wurde zum kunststar
ich war in der gosse verstehen sie
sein jetziger agent hat mich da
herausgeholt und seitdem habe ich ein
neues leben begonnen
ich habe eine sache gelernt wenn es
keine äußere macht gibt die dich zwingt
etwas zu tun was du nicht aus eigener
kraft schaffen würdest dann hast du ihn
vergeblich gelegt
bush fragen des bilder hängen heute in
norwegen in den großen museen comic als
nationaler kunstschatz
nichts war vergeblich